monsieur le ministre vendredi dernier
l'océan Viking a accosté dans le port de
Toulon
à son bord 230 migrants dont une
cinquantaine de mineurs secouru en mer
entre la Libye et l'Italie depuis des
semaines ce bateau naviguait sans
destination l'Italie refusait très
fermement de l'accueillir passant outre
les conventions européennes la France a
dû se résoudre l'accueillir pourtant
d'autres voix ayant humanité dignité
soutien et termité était possible
monsieur le ministre vous annonciez
vouloir réguler les flux migratoires
vous annoncez aussi des négociations
pour convaincre l'Italie d'accueillir le
navire alors qu'il était clair que ce
nouveau gouvernement refuserait
finalement vous avez ordonné son accueil
et vous avez ouvert la voie au passeur
l'accueil de ce navire et la gestion de
ces migrants crée un précédent d'une
grande gravité par votre manque de
préparation et d'anticipation des vis de
procédure ont été soulevées par le
manque de moyens que vous accordez la
justice leur citation leur situation n'a
pas pu être examiné dans les temps la
conséquence c'est comment je vous parle
des migrants sont libres sans que leur
situation n'est été examinée faute de
moyens légaux la rétention des mineurs
ont déjà fugué pour incapacité à
intervenir surtout à anticiper les
difficultés mais gravement en cause la
responsabilité du gouvernement votre
prédécesseur Gérard Coulomb nous apprend
qu'il a préféré démissionner plutôt que
de se voir imposé par le Président de la
République la création d'un grand centre
d'accueil de migrants dans la ville de
Toulon et de générer ce genre de
situation et ses inquiétudes pour les
habitants de Toulon et du Var
évidemment nous serons jamais
insensibles à la souffrance des enfants
des femmes ou des hommes qui recherchent
l'asile mais le voyez-vous pas mais ne
voyez-vous pas que dans nos territoires
déjà fragilisés et qui manque que le
moyen nous sommes aujourd'hui incapables
de les assumer nous ne voulons pas que
nos côtes deviennent de nouvelles cibles
privilégiées pour les passeurs ma
question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre qu'allez-vous faire si de
nouveaux bateaux se présente à quoi les
toulonner et les Français
[Applaudissements]